تذكره فوق الخيال لقمه النصر والهلال ضد
باريس سان جيرمان والاعلان عن قميص فريق
موسم الرياض ومحاوله سرقه منزل جاتوه هذه
الاخبار وغيرها نقدمها لكم من العربيه
رياضه اهلا بكم
اعلن رئيس الهيئه العامه
يبدا بمليون ريال سعودي وينتهي المزاد في
السابعه عشر من الشهر الحالي
مباراه القمه بين نجوم النصر والهلال في
مواجهه باريس سان جيرمان الفرنسي ويستضيف
استاذ الملك فهد المواجهه في التاسعه عشر
من يناير الجاري بحضور ميسي
التذكره بميزات حضور التتويج عن قرب
والدخول الى غرف اللاعبين وسيعود ريع
التذكره الى منصه احسان الخير بدوره نشر
نادي باريس سان جيرمان بيان وضح من خلاله
تفاصيل رحلته الى الدوحه ومن بعدها الى
الرياض للمشاركه في مباراه القمه بحضور
نجوم الفريق
كما تم اليوم ايضا طرح القميص الذي سيظهر
به الفريق المختلط من النصر والهلال ويحمل
الزي الوان المستوحاه من شعار موسم الرياض
المفعم بالالوان المبهجه الى جانب اللون
الابيض وجاء الاعلان عن القميص بصوره
لممثلي الفرق كريستيانو رونالدو من جانب
النصر وسالم الدوسري من الهلال
كاد منزل مدرب كره القدم واللاعب السابق
جاتوزو ان يتعرض للسرقه لكنه نجم الايطالي
نجح في احباط العمليه وذلك بواسطه
استخدامه لنظام التقني متقدم للحمايه
وبالاستعانه بكلاب الحراسه وكانت عصابه من
النصوص هاجمت منزل جاتو في فالنسيا اثناء
مباراه نادي فالنسيا الذي يدربه في الدوري
الاسباني وتاتي محاوله السرقه ضمن السلسله
من السرقات التي تستهدف نجوم كره القدم في
اسبانيا اثناء تواجدهم في الملعب
وصل جمهور نادي الاتحاد صدار الترتيب
الدوري السعودي لكن من حيث عدد الحضور
الجماهيري حيث تجاوز عدد المشجعين في
مباريات النادي الجداوي 200 الف مشجع خلال
اثنتي عشره مباراه منها ست مباريات على
ارضه ويتفوق الاتحاد على اقرب ملاحقها
النصر باكثر من 80000 مشجع
[موسيقى]